There's what we wish for and there's what we get. For Susan Bergman, the story went like this. Her father led a double life. On the one hand, he proudly described himself as a family man, a church organist, in a denomination that was so strict the women covered their heads, wore no make-up, no dancing, no smoking, no drinking, no going to theaters, no swimming with members of the opposite sex, even. Her father stage-managed things so they appeared to be the perfect blond-haired, blue-eyed, American family. But secretly, he was having sex with men. By all accounts, it was lots of men. Sometimes he would even fly off to New York, go to gay clubs there.
生活中有我们期盼的事，也有我们最终得到的事。对苏珊·伯格曼来说，故事是这样的：她的父亲过着双重生活。一方面，他引以为豪地称自己是一个顾家的男人、一名教会风琴手，身处一个极为保守的教派中——那里的女性要遮住头发、不化妆、不跳舞、不吸烟、不喝酒，甚至连看戏和与异性一同游泳都是被禁止的。她的父亲一手操办了一切，使他们看起来是一个金发碧眼、完美的美国中产家庭。但私下里，他却在与男性发生性关系。据各方说法，对象还不少。有时他甚至会飞到纽约，去那里的同性恋俱乐部。
In 1983, he was one of the first victims of AIDS. They had barely named the disease. The symptoms weren't familiar. And he died before his children got the chance to ask him about who he really was and talk to him about how they should reconcile who he had pretended to be all those years, with who he was. What was real of their childhood?
1983年，他成了最早期的艾滋病受害者之一。当时人们几乎还没给这种病命名，症状也不为人所知。他在孩子们有机会询问他究竟是谁，并与他谈论如何调和多年来他扮演的角色与真实自我之间的矛盾之前，就去世了。他们童年里的哪些部分是真实的呢？
Susan Bergman wrote a book about her family's experience. And on her book tour, a very particular thing started to happen. Gay men, who were still married or who had been married, started to contact her. They wanted to explain her father's double life to her. They wanted to explain their own double lives to her. And they wanted to offer her the conversation that she never got to have with her father.
苏珊·伯格曼写了一本关于她家庭经历的书。在她的新书巡回宣传中，一件非常特别的事情发生了。那些仍然维持婚姻或曾经结过婚的男同性恋者开始联系她。他们想向她解释她父亲的双重生活，想向她解释他们自己的双重生活。他们想提供给她那种她从未能与父亲进行的对话。
Well, from WBEZ in Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Back once again for another hour documenting life in these United States. Today's program in four acts. Act One, gay men. I talk to Susan Bergman about her father. Act Two, a gay man talks to me in a parked car in an undisclosed location about why he thinks that his children don't need to know that he's gay and why he stays married. Act Three, we take all the heavy, very heavy themes about lying and families from the first two acts and rework them as comedy, if you can believe that. And finally, Act Four, the sins of the fathers pass on to the sons. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》(This American Life) 节目，我是艾拉·格拉斯。再次回归，为你记录这片美国大地上的生活。今天的节目分为四幕。第一幕，男同性恋者。我与苏珊·伯格曼谈论她的父亲。第二幕，一位男同性恋者在未公开地点的停放车辆中，与我探讨为什么他认为自己的孩子不需要知道他是同性恋，以及为什么他选择维持婚姻。第三幕，我们将前两幕中关于谎言和家庭的沉重主题进行重构，将其转化为喜剧，如果你敢相信的话。最后，第四幕，父辈的罪孽传递给子辈。请继续收听。
Act One, The Book Tour. Susan Bergman came to our studios, loaded down with evidence.
第一幕，《新书巡回》。苏珊·伯格曼带着满载的证据来到了我们的演播室。
OK, now you've brought in some tapes of yourself being interviewed on talk radio shows that I've got here. So this first one, do we need to explain it at all before we play it?
好的，现在你带了一些你在谈话广播节目中接受采访的录音带，我这儿都有。那么第一段录音，在播放之前我们需要解释一下背景吗？
I think this was a caller that was, in some ways, typical of the response that I got on talk radio.
我认为这是一个听众打来的电话，他在某种程度上代表了我在谈话广播中收到的典型反馈。
Here we go.
开始了。
I have a particularly close connection to this sort of thing. I'm a gay father, divorced now. So I'm very close to this. In particular, I can understand your father's secretiveness and his pain. There's always the resentment that you had to go through the pain, that you had to hide, that you had to lie. And you live with that resentment. It really never quite goes away, even in my case, after you've come completely out and divorced and the whole bit. And the resentment lives on, that I had to do live that lie, that I had to lie to my wife, that I had to lie to my children, that I had to life to my family. And never be happy. Never, never, never know happiness.
我和这种事情有着特别紧密的联系。我是一位男同性恋父亲，现在已经离婚了。所以我对此感同身受。特别是，我能理解你父亲的隐秘和痛苦。总是会有一种怨恨，怨恨自己不得不经历那种痛苦，不得不隐藏，不得不撒谎。你带着那种怨恨生活。它真的从未完全消失，即使像我这样已经完全出柜并离婚，经历了这一切之后。那种怨恨依然存在：我不得不活在那样的谎言中，不得不对我的妻子撒谎，不得不对我的孩子们撒谎，不得不对我的家庭撒谎。而且永远无法快乐。永远，永远，永远无法知晓幸福。
Hey, Susan?
嘿，苏珊？
Uh-huh.
嗯。
Can I just ask you, what was your reaction to-- when he was saying this, had it occurred to you before that your father would actually be resentful of the family for the secret that he was keeping from you?
我能问问你的反应吗——当他说这些话时，你以前是否想到过，你的父亲实际上会因为他向你隐瞒的秘密而对家庭感到怨恨？
He was angry at us a lot. But it seemed like it was more-- I mean I interpreted that as we were bothering Dad, or Mom was asking too many questions. Yeah. It's not one that had occurred to me. And I would have to contest that assumption that one has to lie or one is put in a situation where lying is the only appropriate gesture or response.
他经常对我们发火。但我过去以为那是……我的意思是，我解读为我们在打扰爸爸，或者妈妈问了太多问题。是的，这个念头我从未有过。而且我不得不反驳那种认为“一个人必须撒谎”或者“一个人身处谎言是唯一合适的姿态或回应”的假设。
Let's go back to this tape.
让我们回到录音。
And I hope that-- I don't know. Is there anything that I can help you. Any questions that I could answer. Because I'm still alive and I've been through it.
我希望……我不知道。有什么我能帮你的吗？有什么我可以回答的问题吗？因为我还活着，而且我经历过这一切。
That's great. Boy, I hope I can do this without just kind of gushing all over you, because it's so great of you to call in and offer that. It's beautiful. I didn't get that chance with my father. I guess I would ask you--
太棒了。天哪，我希望我能不至于在你面前表现得情绪失控，因为你能打来电话并提出这些帮助真是太好了。这很美好。我没有机会与我的父亲进行这样的对话。我想我会问你……
I'm just stopping the tape here. I'm just going to stop the tape here, because as you're listening, you're making the gagging signal at your own reaction.
我在这里暂停录音。我只是要把录音停在这里，因为当你听的时候，你对自己听到的内容做出了呕吐的手势。
Oh, I think that's so great. Oh, I think that's so wonderful. I was not in touch with the full range of the reaction until after I hung up the telephone and stopped the radio interview. And clearly, that man was hurting in a lot of ways. And the last thing I needed to do was have a fight with him on the air about being a liar, or whatever. Whatever anger I would have had towards my father didn't seem to me to apply to him. He was just some innocent bystander. So I just tried to be nice. And it was kind-- oh yeah.
噢，我觉得那太好了。噢，我觉得那太精彩了。在挂掉电话并结束广播采访之前，我并没有意识到自己反应的全貌。很显然，那个男人在很多方面都很痛苦。我最不需要做的就是在直播中为了“他是骗子”之类的事情和他争吵。无论我对父亲有什么愤怒，似乎都无法适用于他。他只是一个无辜的旁观者。所以我尽量保持礼貌。那是一种……噢，是的。
There's the thing that you wish for and there's the thing that you get. And if what you really need is a long talk with your father, the kind of talk where you get mad and argue, and maybe he gets mad, and maybe people admit mistakes, and maybe things get resolved or maybe they don't get resolved, and you learn that they won't get resolved. But if that conversation is what you need, then no stranger on a radio call-in show, however well meaning, is going to give that to you. It's a mockery of what you need.
生活中有你期盼的事，也有你最终得到的事。如果你真正需要的是与父亲进行一场深谈——那种你会生气并争论，或许他也会生气，或许人们会承认错误，或许事情得到解决，又或许事情无法解决，而你学会了它们终将无法解决的谈话——那么广播访谈节目中任何陌生人，无论出于多好的意愿，都无法给予你这些。这只是对你所渴望的东西的一种嘲弄。
But there you are. There you are. You're talking to this man, this stranger. And you find yourself asking a version of the question that you would most like to ask your own father. And you get an answer that is totally useless, because really it has nothing to do with you.
但你就在那里。你就在那里。你在和这个男人，这个陌生人交谈。你发现自己在问一个你最想问自己父亲的问题的版本。然后你得到了一个完全无用的回答，因为说到底，这和你自己的父亲毫无关系。
You said, you didn't want to share your quote, "real life," maybe. But why do you feel that you were forced to lie about that? How could your family have shared your life?
你说过，你不想分享你所谓的“真实生活”，或许吧。但为什么你觉得你被迫对此撒谎？你的家庭原本可以如何分享你的生活？
You see the problem is that once you get trapped into doing the thing you think you're supposed to do at a young age-- I married at 23 because I thought it was-- I knew I was gay then already.
你看，问题在于，一旦你在年轻时就被困在做你认为“应该做”的事情里——我在23岁时结婚，因为我以为那是……我那时已经知道自己是同性恋了。
Hm.
嗯。
So did my wife, for that matter. She put it aside.
我妻子也知道。她只是把它搁置了。
Gay men sent Susan Bergman photos of themselves. One happy couple stands there in one of the photos in matching sweaters, raising glasses, smiling. The letter said that if her father had lived and divorced her mother, this is the kind of happiness he could have had. The letters that Susan Bergman got from the children and spouses of gay fathers, she said, seemed to be written in a completely different language than the letters she got from the gay fathers. It was like two different cultures, two different perspectives.
男同性恋者给苏珊·伯格曼寄来了他们的照片。其中一张照片里，一对幸福的伴侣穿着配套的毛衣，举杯微笑。信中说，如果她的父亲还活着并与母亲离婚，他本可以拥有这种幸福。苏珊·伯格曼从那些男同性恋父亲的子女和配偶那里收到的信件，她说，似乎是用一种完全不同的语言写成的，与她从那些男同性恋父亲那里收到的信完全不同。就像两种不同的文化、两种不同的视角。
There are lots of books about men coming out, gay men coming out, gay women coming out. But nobody seemed to be able to remember a book that had been told from the point of view of the children and the wives that these gay men had left behind. And families who are in that situation felt this shock of we are not alone. And they contacted her.
有很多关于男人出柜、男同性恋者出柜、女同性恋者出柜的书。但似乎没人能想起有一本书是从这些被遗弃的子女和妻子的角度来讲述的。那些处于这种情况下的家庭感受到了这种震惊：我们并不孤单。于是他们联系了她。
You brought examples of letters?
你带来了信件的例子吗？
Yeah. The most poignant letter that I got, this woman says she read the book. "Our lives are so similar, Susan, that it was eerie for me to read." She talks about their background. They were all so fundamentalist. Our family wasn't quite fundamentalist. But this woman says, "Bible believing churches that started in their living room. We had six well-behaved, talented, athletic children in our prosperous and highly visible family."
是的。我收到的最令人心酸的信件里，这位女士说她读了这本书。“我们的生活太相似了，苏珊，读的时候我觉得毛骨悚然。”她谈到了他们的背景。他们都非常原教旨主义。我们的家庭并不完全是原教旨主义的。但这位女士说，“在客厅里发起的信奉圣经的教会。在我们富有且备受瞩目的家庭里，我们有六个乖巧、有天赋、热爱运动的孩子。”
"When my dad was diagnosed in 1988," she writes, "my mom kicked him out of the house and would have nothing else to do with him. Three of us moved him out of town, encouraged him to change his name, and lied about his mysterious disease and our parent's sudden separation. Now, they are both gone. And we are left to deal with the fraud that was our life."
“1988年我父亲被确诊时，”她写道，“我母亲把他赶出了家门，对他不理不睬。我们三个孩子把他搬到了外地，鼓励他改名换姓，并对他那神秘的疾病和父母的突然分居撒了谎。现在，他们俩都走了。我们只能去处理那些曾经构成我们生活的谎言。”
They had just buried their mother-- when she wrote me this letter-- who had died of AIDS because the father didn't protect the mother at all. She says, "I'm writing to you now, not to pour out my heart, but to ask if my sisters and I can come take you out for lunch soon there in Chicago? There are not many like us who have suffered such circumstances. And I know in my heart that I should be able to hold my head high and talk about my mother's needless death without shame. But as of now, I can't."
当她写这封信给我时，他们刚刚埋葬了母亲——她死于艾滋病，因为父亲根本没有保护过母亲。她说，“我写信给你，不是为了倾诉心声，而是想问问我的姐妹们和我是否能在芝加哥和你共进午餐？像我们这样遭受过这种情况的人不多。我在心里知道，我应该昂首挺胸，毫无羞愧地谈论母亲那不必要的死亡。但目前，我还做不到。”
That's the end of that letter. And I talked to this family at length, on several different occasions. They did come to Chicago.
那封信到这里就结束了。我在好几次不同的场合与这个家庭进行了深入交谈。他们确实来了芝加哥。
They did?
他们真的来了？
Yeah. Two of the daughters came. Some of the sons were not willing to even acknowledge that the parents had died of AIDS yet, one of them being a physician.
是的。其中两个女儿来了。有些儿子甚至不愿承认父母是死于艾滋病，其中一个还是医生。
One of the sons being a physician?
其中一个儿子是医生？
Yeah. But the interesting story that they have, as her father was dying, they spent hours and hours interviewing their father on tape about his sexual contacts. They got the names of all of the married men that he had been with in this three-city area and the addresses and the phone numbers, which he had. And they began calling those men's wives on the telephone, because they wanted to save lives, because they knew their mother was dying.
是的。但他们有一个有趣的故事。在父亲弥留之际，他们花了数小时在录音带上采访父亲关于他性接触的情况。他们得到了他在这个三城市地区接触过的所有已婚男性的名单，还有地址和电话号码，这些都是他留下的。他们开始给那些男人的妻子打电话，因为他们想挽救生命，因为他们知道自己的母亲快要死了。
And so they would call up these women and say, you don't know me but--
所以他们会打电话给这些女人说，你不认识我，但是——
Yup.
是的。
--my father has had sex with your husband.
——我父亲和你丈夫发生过性关系。
Yes. I mean can you imagine that? I mean, of course they debated this among themselves. They thought this is none of our business. But when their mother got AIDS, they knew that this list of 100 married men were not taking any precautions with their own wives. And they started calling. And I said, "Well, what was the reaction?" I asked them to go on. And they said a lot of women hung up the phone them. And some would say, "Oh, thank you very much for calling."
是的。我的意思是，你能想象吗？当然，他们自己在内部也争论过。他们认为这不关我们的事。但当他们的母亲感染艾滋病后，他们知道名单上的那100个已婚男人在与自己的妻子相处时并没有采取任何预防措施。于是他们开始打电话。我问他们：“那么，她们的反应是什么？”他们说，很多女人挂断了电话。也有一些人会说：“噢，非常感谢你的来电。”
And as you say that, the thing that occurs to me is it's such a complicated act, because partly it's an act of compassion for somebody. And then partly it's such an act of vengeance against somebody else, and calling--
当你这样说时，我想到的是，这是一种极其复杂的行为。因为在某种程度上，它是对某人的怜悯，而在另一方面，它又是对另一方的复仇，揭露——
I know but--
我知道，但是——
--out that man.
——那个男人的真面目。
I mean if you lose your mother to AIDS, I can see why. I never had to do that.
我的意思是，如果你因艾滋病失去了母亲，我能理解为什么。我从没经历过那种事。
Yeah.
是的。
But I'll tell you, in the town I live in, outside Chicago, there is a family, at least one, where the same thing is going on. The father is very promiscuous, a prominent man in town, has four young children. His wife has no idea he's a practicing homosexual. They have unprotected sex. And people in the community come to me and say, "What should we do? We've asked him to tell her. We're thinking about telling her. We want to protect her so that her kids have one parent." And when I talk to--
但我得告诉你，在我居住的芝加哥郊外的一个小镇，有一个家庭，至少有一个，正在发生同样的事。那个父亲非常滥交，是镇上的知名人物，有四个年幼的孩子。他的妻子根本不知道他是一个活跃的同性恋者。他们有不安全的性行为。社区里的人来找我说：“我们该怎么办？我们让他告诉她。我们正在考虑要不要告诉她。我们想保护她，这样她的孩子们至少能有一个健康的父母。”当我与——
And what do you tell them?
那你告诉他们什么？
I say that's their decision. They're going to have to really think about that, because I don't know the people. I can't go into their lives just because I wrote some book on some related subject. If they're involved in the family system in some way, they have to make that decision. I have no idea. But when I talk to gay men about this book, who have read it and want to have a conversation, almost everyone has said to me, "Oh yeah, my main partners are married men." I said, "Well, you have to think about your own responsibility to the family then, I imagine."
我说那是他们的决定。他们必须真正考虑清楚，因为我不认识这些人。我不能因为我写了一本相关的书就闯入他们的生活。如果他们以某种方式卷入了那个家庭系统，他们就必须做出那个决定。我不知道。但当我与读过这本书并想进行交流的男同性恋者谈话时，几乎每个人都对我说：“噢，是的，我的主要伴侣都是已婚男人。”我说：“嗯，我想那你得考虑一下你对那些家庭应尽的责任了。”
All these different fathers who contacted you, did any of them say, I'm sorry, I did something that hurt people and I'm sorry?
所有联系你的那些不同父亲，有没有人说，对不起，我做了一些伤害别人的事，我很抱歉？
Well, no. Because there's a lot of talk trying to defend the position that's just newly being articulated in their lives. And I understand that they're building their ramparts or whatever.
嗯，没有。因为有大量的谈话都在试图捍卫他们生活中刚刚被阐明的立场。我理解他们正在修筑防御工事之类的东西。
That position being, I was right to at least clear up this lie.
那个立场就是：至少我有权揭开这个谎言，我是对的。
Finally, I did the one right thing. I left my family and became a true homosexual. That's the right thing, that's being defended in almost all of the letters.
“最后，我做了一件正确的事。我离开了我的家庭，成为了一名真正的同性恋者。”这是对的，这几乎是所有信件中都在捍卫的事情。
This is a very interesting letter signed, anonymously yours. He says, "At the risk of intrusion, which is not my intention, I'm compelled to write you and express some gentle viewpoints based on experiences similar to those in your book, but admittedly little real knowledge of your life." I appreciated that acknowledgement very much.
这是一封非常有意思的信，署名是“匿名”。他说：“冒昧打扰，并非我的本意，但我迫切地写信给你，表达一些温和的观点。这些基于与你书中相似的经历，尽管我确实对你的生活知之甚少。”我非常感激这种承认。
"Based on your writing, however, I strongly feel that your father's life with you and your family was not the sham it may superficially appear. I see the story from a different perspective, as that of a tragic, often unconscious struggle by your father to love his family and not end up as one of nature's mistakes, which of course he wasn't. Were there no kisses of bruised knees, soothing of tears and hurt feelings, umpteen occasions of personal denial, dreams of success and happiness for you and the others? Would it be unreasonable to consider yourself doubly-loved, by a fractured psyche fighting desperately against the nature he was given? In retrospect, are not his intents as important as his failures?"
“然而，根据你的写作，我强烈地感觉到，你父亲与你和你家人一起的生活，并不像表面上看起来的那样是一场虚构。我从不同的视角看待这个故事，认为这只是一个悲剧性的、常常是无意识的斗争：你的父亲试图爱他的家庭，且不让自己沦为‘自然的错误’——当然他不是。难道没有亲吻擦伤的膝盖、抚慰眼泪和受伤的感情，无数次个人否定的场合，对你和其他人成功与幸福的梦想吗？考虑自己被双重爱着，被一个正在与他被赋予的天性进行绝望斗争的破碎心灵所爱，难道是不合理的吗？回想起来，他的意图难道不比他的失败更重要吗？”
It's a beautiful letter in some ways. And in other ways, there are these irritants in these approaches. I shouldn't be so critical I suppose, but then to say to me, were there no kisses of bruised knees? Yes, of course. Yeah, I had a great Daddy in many regards. Yes, he was a split person. And I don't think that he enjoyed being split, and neither does this gentleman. But that doesn't make him a better father. And that's almost the thing that this letter is driving towards, like couldn't you be doubly loved, being loved by a homosexual father? No.
这在某些方面是一封美丽的信。但在另一些方面，这些做法里有一些令人恼火的东西。我不该这么挑剔，但若问我“难道没有亲吻擦伤的膝盖吗？”是的，当然有。是的，他在许多方面是一个伟大的爸爸。是的，他是一个分裂的人。我不认为他享受这种分裂，那位先生也不认为。但这并不让他成为一个更好的父亲。那封信几乎是朝着这个方向驱动的，仿佛在说：难道被一个同性恋父亲爱着，你就没有得到双倍的爱吗？不。
I think I was well-loved by my father. I think my father was a split person, and that that destroyed him and it worked towards the destruction of his family. By coming to understand that your family was structured around a lie, that who you were told you were and that the family was, has nothing to do with what you really are or were, that's very complicated.
我想我确实被我的父亲深深爱着。我认为我的父亲是一个分裂的人，这摧毁了他，也导致了他家庭的破碎。通过理解你的家庭是围绕着一个谎言构建的，理解你被告知你是谁，被告知这个家庭是什么，与你真正是什么或曾是什么毫无关系，那真是非常复杂。
Susan Bergman. Her book is called Anonymity. Coming up, a gay father explains why he chooses not to tell his children of his double life.
苏珊·伯格曼。她的书名为《匿名》(Anonymity)。接下来，一位男同性恋父亲解释了他为什么选择不告诉孩子们他的双重生活。
Act Two, Dad in the Closet. This next story isn't intended to answer whatever questions Susan Bergman might have about her father. It's intended to answer our questions about these gay men who stay in their marriages, leading double lives.
第二幕，柜子里的爸爸。接下来的这个故事并非旨在回答苏珊·伯格曼可能对自己父亲的任何疑问。它旨在回答我们关于那些留在婚姻中、过着双重生活的男同性恋者的问题。
The man we found to interview for this has been married for 26 years, heads a support group, called Review, for men in similar circumstances. He was willing to be interviewed, but he didn't want me coming to his home and he didn't want to come to our studios either. On the phone, I understood this to mean that he didn't feel comfortable appearing in public like this. Later, he told me that I had misunderstood, that he just didn't want to drive that far. In any case, we met in a parking lot on Damen Avenue and drove to a quiet street, where I conducted the interview, in his car.
我们找到采访的这位男士已经结婚26年，负责一个名为“回顾”(Review)的互助小组，专门针对处于类似情况的男性。他愿意接受采访，但他不希望我去他的家，也不想来我们的演播室。在电话里，我理解为他不想以这种方式在公众面前露面。后来他告诉我，是我误解了，他只是不想开那么远的车。总之，我们在达门大道(Damen Avenue)的一个停车场见面，然后开车到了一条安静的街道上，我在他的车里进行了采访。
My name is Jerry Walters.
我叫杰里·沃尔特斯。
Now let me just ask you, is it OK for us to use your name on the radio?
现在让我问一下，我们在广播中使用你的名字可以吗？
Jerry Walters isn't my real name. It's a name that when I used to work on a hotline, they said pick out a name that you're comfortable with and use that. And so that's what I've been using. Plus, it separates business from my club activities. So Jerry Walters is fine.
杰里·沃尔特斯不是我的真名。以前我在热线工作时，他们说选一个你觉得舒服的名字用。所以我就一直用这个。而且，这把生意和我的俱乐部活动区分开了。所以叫杰里·沃尔特斯没问题。
This man is in his fifties, was a teenager during the Eisenhower years. He looked like any suburban dad. He was neatly dressed, in gray wool slacks, a sweater, and what appeared to be a clip-on necktie. He says he was always a good boy. He says he doesn't really get at angry people, doesn't know how to yell at people. Back in high school, he says, he was the kind of boy who'd go out with girls, but never make passes at them.
这个男人五十多岁，在艾森豪威尔时期度过了青少年时代。他看起来就像任何一个郊区老爸。他衣着整洁，穿着灰色羊毛长裤、一件毛衣，还有看起来像是夹上去的领带。他说他一直是个好孩子。他说他真的不会对人生气，不知道怎么对人咆哮。回想起高中时，他说他是那种会和女孩约会，但从不跟她们调情的那种男孩。
I graduated. I would date occasionally. And I did find somebody that seemed like a very nice person, that we had a lot in common. And we went out on a date. But that afternoon, after I met her in the morning, and that afternoon I had my first gay experience. And so, it was really kind of a red-letter day. I went bowling with her in the evening. And I was out with another man that afternoon.
我毕业了。我偶尔会约会。我确实找到了一个看起来很不错的人，我们有很多共同点。我们约会过。但在那次约会的下午——那天早上遇见她，下午我就有了第一次同性体验。所以，那真是值得纪念的一天。晚上我和她一起去保龄球，那天下午我却和另一个男人在一起。
So I thought well, the situation with the other man was scary and disappointing and painful, to say the least. And so I thought, well, fine. That's out of my system. I don't want any more of that.
所以我心想，好吧，和那个男人的事既可怕又令人失望，痛苦不堪，至少可以说。所以我心想，好吧，没事了。我已经把它排除出我的生活了。我不想再那样了。
He went on to marry the girl, who he's still married to nearly three decades later. But soon after their wedding, he became increasingly obsessed with men. He found himself driving out to the forest preserves, where gay men were known to hang out. Men would walk over to his car. Men would try to talk to him.
他继续娶了那个女孩，并将近三十年后依然维持着婚姻。但在婚礼后不久，他变得越来越痴迷于男性。他发现自己开车去森林保护区，那里是众所周知的同性恋聚集地。男人们会走到他的车边，男人们会试图和他搭讪。
And I would drive out of the forest preserve areas like a bat out of hell, to be perfectly honest. And thinking that, fine, I didn't do anything. So there's no reason for me to feel guilty. But I would end up with headaches that were so severe that I couldn't work. I would come home four or five days a week, and just be incapacitated with the pain. But then I was taking aspirins and Tylenol, and everything else. I got hooked on tranquilizers. And it's a scary thing.
老实说，我会像躲避瘟神一样飞快地从森林保护区开车逃离。心里想着，没关系，我什么都没做。所以我没理由感到内疚。但最后我总是会头痛剧烈到无法工作。我每周有四五天回到家时，因疼痛而失去行动能力。那时候我服用阿司匹林、泰诺还有其他各种药。我对镇静剂上瘾了。那真是件可怕的事。
When this obsession first takes hold, where first you are thinking about it, and before you know it, you are completely consumed by the thought of doing something with another male. You're not even sure of what you want to do. You're not sure who you want to do it with or where these people are, but you are totally consumed with that quest. Well suddenly, my wife became the person that was stopping me from pursuing what I absolutely, positively had to do to survive. And your thinking gets distorted, would be an understatement.
当这种执念第一次扎根时，起初你只是在思考它，不知不觉中，你完全被这种和另一个男性做点什么的念头所消耗。你甚至不确定你想做什么。你不确定你想和谁做，也不确定这些人都在哪里，但你完全被那种追求所消耗。突然间，我的妻子成了那个阻碍我追求为了生存绝对必须要做的事情的人。说你的思维变得扭曲，那都算轻的。
Why what happens? What do you start to think about?
为什么？发生了什么？你开始想些什么？
Maybe I shouldn't say this and maybe it's unique in my situation, but you think, gee, if she had an accident or something-- yes, I knew-- it sounds bizarre. But you're almost ready to plot to kill somebody. And I've told her this. And it's something that we-- here's a very mild mannered person, almost plotting somebody's demise, because they're stopping you. And they don't even know what's going on at this point.
也许我不该说这些，也许这在我的处境中很特殊，但你会想，天哪，如果她出了什么意外之类的……是的，我知道，这听起来很古怪。但你几乎准备策划杀人。我告诉过她这一点。而且这……这是一个非常温和的人，几乎在策划谋杀某人，因为他们在阻碍你。而当时他们甚至不知道发生了什么。
Do you think that at that time, before you told your wife, do think that in a day-to-day way, you had a lot of resentment that you would act out on, you would snap at her, that you would just be short with her? Because what you are describing is being so resentful.
你认为在那个时候，在你告诉妻子之前，你是否觉得在日常生活中，你有很多怨恨会表现出来？你会对她发脾气，你会对她很不耐烦吗？因为你所描述的正是那种强烈的怨恨。
No, I didn't. I held it inside. You see, this was your wife. You can't do this. I'm one of these people that holds the door open for women and very courteous with people. So I held it inside. And you think the top of your head is going to blow off instead.
不，我没有。我把它藏在心里。你看，这是你的妻子。你不能那样做。我是那种会为女性扶门，对人非常有礼貌的人。所以我把它藏在心里。你只会觉得自己的头顶快要炸开了。
Finally, after two years of marriage, he got up the courage to tell his wife he wanted to have sex with men.
最终，结婚两年后，他鼓起勇气告诉妻子他想和男人发生性关系。
She says, "Oh, is that all?" And I said, "You don't understand. I've got these feelings for men and I don't know how to deal with them." And she says, "Well, I married all of you. I didn't marry part of you. We'll just figure out how to deal with it." And so from there, we just set the guidelines that would work for us. I asked her what she needed to be comfortable? She wanted, number one, to know where I would be. And that's fine. I would sooner leave a phone number underneath the telephone, that if I don't show up by 10 o'clock or 12 o'clock, she calls.
她说：“噢，就这些？”我说：“你不明白。我有这些对男人的感觉，我不知道该怎么处理。”她说：“嗯，我嫁的是完整的你，不是一部分的你。我们会找出处理它的方法。”所以从那时起，我们就设定了对我们有效的准则。我问她，她需要什么才能感到舒服？她说，第一，想知道我会去哪里。那很好。我宁愿把电话号码留在电话下面，如果我10点或12点还没回去，她就打电话。
She wanted me to be home when the kids got home, or when the kids woke up in the morning, which is fine. The term, "are you sleeping with somebody," I think, is kind of stupid. If I'm going someplace to sleep, I'll sleep at home. I'm going out for sex, not for sleeping. So that was never a problem. That's really the only things. And she said, "I want to be the most important person in your life." And she always has been and she always will be.
她希望孩子们放学回家时，或者孩子们早上醒来时，我能在家里，这很好。“你有没有和别人睡觉”这个词，我觉得挺傻的。如果我要去什么地方睡觉，我会回家睡。我出去是为了性，不是为了睡觉。所以那从来不是问题。真的就是这些。她说：“我想成为你生命中最重要的人。”她一直都是，也永远会是。
He says, of course, he uses condoms. So he doesn't being home any infections or AIDS. His children and the people he works with don't know he's gay, though after his father died, he told his mother.
他说，当然，他使用避孕套。所以他不会把任何感染或艾滋病带回家。他的孩子和他一起工作的人不知道他是同性恋，尽管他父亲去世后，他告诉了他的母亲。
Why stay married?
为什么要维持婚姻？
Because I love her and she loves me. And we're probably the best thing that happened to each other, ever. See, I don't like-- there's a difference between gay feelings and living the gay lifestyle, a dramatic difference. And I know a lot of people will disagree with this and maybe take offense at this. There is an arrested adolescence in the gay community. There is an acceptance of lying because it was needed to survive. And honesty is something that I really put a high price on and I really value it.
因为我爱她，她也爱我。我们可能是彼此生命中发生过的最好的事。看，我不喜欢……同性恋感受和过同性恋生活方式之间是有区别的，巨大的区别。我知道很多人会不同意这一点，也许会为此感到被冒犯。同性恋社区里有一种被捕的青少年心态。有一种对谎言的接受，因为那是生存所必需的。而诚实是我真正看重并给予很高价值的东西。
I suggest to him that he's the one who lies, by staying in a straight marriage, and not telling his own children he's gay. He says he's not really lying to his children. As he explains it, there's no easy time to sit your kids down and tell them that you're gay. When they're 5 or 10, it'll make no sense. When they hit adolescence, it could be confusing, a kind of burden, as they sort through their own sexual identities.
我向他指出，正是他自己通过维持一段异性恋婚姻，并且不告诉自己的孩子他是同性恋，而在撒谎。他说他并没有真的对孩子们撒谎。照他的解释，没有一个简单的时间点可以坐下来告诉孩子们你是同性恋。当他们5岁或10岁时，这毫无意义。当他们进入青春期时，这可能会令人困惑，成为一种负担，因为他们正在整理自己的性认同。
If his children ask him directly he says, then he'll tell the truth. And he says, they'll ask when they're ready to hear the answer.
他说，如果他的孩子们直接问他，他会说实话。他说，当他们准备好听到答案时，他们自然会问。
If you want to know something, you will ask the question. If you don't ask the question, either you know the answer or you don't want to deal with the answer. Am I right?
如果你想知道某件事，你会提问。如果你不提问，要么是你已经知道答案，要么是你不想面对答案。对吗？
How old are your children?
你的孩子们多大了？
They're in their 20's. They're girls.
她们二十多岁了，是两个女儿。
Hm. Well, what is your assessment of what's going on? Do you think that they know, but they choose not to ask consciously?
嗯，那么，你如何评价现在发生的一切？你觉得她们知情，但为了刻意回避而选择不去询问吗？
Yes.
是的。
And it's a conscious choice?
那是一个有意识的选择吗？
Yes. I think it's very much a conscious choice. I think that they accept me for who I am. And I don't think they want to know a whole lot more about it.
是的，我认为这绝对是有意识的选择。我觉得她们接受真实的我，而且我不认为她们想知道太多关于这方面的事。
But you're saying they accept you for who you are, but they don't actually know entirely who you are, because you keep a certain part from them.
但你说她们接受真实的我，可她们并不完全了解你是谁，因为你对她们隐瞒了一部分。
I am who my children see. The only thing different about me is that I have sex with men. That is the only difference. If that makes me a different person in their eyes, what value is that? How is that going to enhance me as a father if suddenly this is in the equation too? I'm a good father. I'm a good husband. I take care of them. I was there when they needed things, and with school and growing up and advice and everything. And I don't think that what a person does in their bedroom, or someone else's bedroom, really is your children's concern.
我的孩子们看到的就是真实的我。我和别人唯一的不同就是我和男人发生性关系，这才是唯一的区别。如果这在她们眼中让我变成了一个不同的人，那这有什么价值呢？如果突然之间把这个因素加进来，这怎么会提升我作为父亲的形象呢？我是一个好父亲，一个好丈夫。我照顾她们。当她们需要帮助，在学校生活、成长和寻求建议时，我一直都在。我不认为一个人在自己的卧室——或者别人的卧室——里做什么，真正需要由你的孩子们来操心。
Later in our conversation, Jerry says that he'd like to tell his daughters the truth, but his wife doesn't want him to. She doesn't want anybody to know. He feels he has to respect her wishes. I ask him if his wife is simply ashamed that other people will know her husband looks for sex outside of the marriage? No, says Jerry. She knows the marriage works for them and simply doesn't want to have to put up with the opinions of people who won't understand. And they do have a sex life, Jerry says, of a sort.
在稍后的对话中，杰瑞说他想告诉女儿们真相，但他妻子不让他这么做。她不想让任何人知道。他觉得他必须尊重妻子的意愿。我问他，他妻子是不是仅仅因为担心别人知道她丈夫在婚外寻求性生活而感到羞耻？杰瑞说不。她知道这段婚姻对他们来说是奏效的，她只是不想应付那些无法理解的人的议论。杰瑞说，他们确实有某种形式的性生活。
Are you as sexually attracted to women as you are to men?
你对女性的性吸引力和对男性一样强烈吗？
No. We don't depend on each other for our sexual satisfaction. I don't know if I should go into that or not. Probably not. Masturbation is something that is part of what we do for sexual satisfaction. And however you do it, it's satisfying.
不。我们不会依赖对方来满足性需求。我不知道我是否应该深入谈论这个。可能不应该。手淫是我们获取性满足的一部分。不管你怎么做，这都是满足的。
Does she see other men?
她会和别的男人在一起吗？
No. She says that's not what I'm about.
不。她说这不是她的风格。
We talked for two hours. It started to get cold in the car. Over time, as we talked, it became clear that this man stayed in his marriage, partly because he couldn't imagine any other life for himself. To Jerry, being an adult means having a wife, a house in the burbs, a couple kids, dinner parties, and mortgage payments, and mowing the lawn.
我们谈了两个小时，车里开始冷了。随着谈话的深入，我很清楚，这个男人留在婚姻中，部分原因是他无法想象自己还有别的生活。对杰瑞来说，成年就意味着有妻子、郊区的房子、几个孩子、晚餐聚会、房贷和修剪草坪。
That was the only way that people lived. I mean anything else wasn't even considered. And so how could I be anything other than what I am? And that was to be a married man.
那是人们唯一的生活方式。我的意思是，其他任何方式根本不在考虑范围内。所以我怎么可能变成除我之外的其他样子呢？那就是做一个已婚男人。
Do you think that you could have a kind of relationship like you have with your wife, with another man?
你觉得你能和另一个男人建立那种和你妻子一样的关系吗？
No.
不能。
I tell him that these kind of long-term, marriage-like relationships are commonplace among the gay men I know.
我告诉他，这类长期的、类似婚姻的关系在我认识的男同性恋者中很常见。
In the suburbs, it's not commonplace. Let's face it. In the city it's accepted. There are areas in the city where men can hold hands, where men can show affection outwardly. You won't find that in the suburbs.
在郊区，这不常见。让我们面对现实吧。在城市里，这被接受。城市里有一些区域，男人可以手牵手，可以公开表达爱意。你在郊区是找不到这些的。
But I find there's a part of you which doesn't even believe that it exists.
但我发现你内心深处甚至不相信那种关系的存在。
It doesn't, where I live.
在我住的地方，它确实不存在。
For a while, I told him about Susan Bergman's book, about how difficult it was for her when she realized that her father wasn't what he seemed. I suggested to Jerry that his own daughters might feel betrayed, might find it hard to trust him if someday they find out he's been less than candid about his sexuality. He didn't agree.
有一段时间，我跟他讲了苏珊·伯格曼的书，讲到当她发现父亲并非她所看到的那样时，她内心是多么痛苦。我向杰瑞暗示，如果有一天他的女儿们发现他对自己性取向的问题一直不够坦诚，她们可能会感到被背叛，可能会觉得难以再信任他。他不同意。
Shall we take the Easter Bunny and Santa Claus in that context too, that your parents told you that this man is Santa Claus? Do you hate your parents or distrust your parents' judgment from that point on? When you were a child, you were given just enough information to live your life. They didn't tell you that the landlord's going to throw you out of the house. They didn't tell you that your father's going to lose his job. They didn't tell you a lot of the things that could hurt you, because they were your parents. Their job was to protect you.
那我们是不是也该把复活节兔和圣诞老人的事放在这个语境下讨论？你父母告诉你这世上有圣诞老人。从那时起，你就恨你的父母或者不信任他们的判断了吗？当你还是个孩子时，你只得到了足够让你活下去的信息。他们没告诉你房东会把你赶出去。他们没告诉你你父亲会失业。他们没告诉你很多可能会伤害你的事情，因为他们是你的父母。他们的工作是保护你。
Her situation is that her father was, on the surface anyway, presented the image of being a family man, a very religious man--
她的情况是，她父亲表面上呈现出的形象是一个顾家的男人，一个非常虔诚的男人——
Right.
没错。
--was a musician in their church. And so there was this constant lie, because--
——是教会里的音乐家。所以这就存在一个持续的谎言，因为——
Where is the lie? Was he not all of those things? Wasn't he all of those things, plus one other thing? We are complicated individuals. We can be a lot of things. You said he was a musician. He was a family man. He was a minister. He was a lot of things. And he was just this one more thing, that he didn't choose to share with her. And I think that was his privilege.
谎言在哪里？他难道不是那些身份吗？他不仅是那些身份，还多了一样东西，不是吗？我们是复杂的个体。我们可以有很多面。你说他是音乐家，他是顾家男人，他是牧师，他是很多东西。而他只是多了一样他不想与她分享的东西。我觉得那是他的特权。
How much do you need to know a person to love them, to live with them? Jerry says he talks to about 260 men a year in the support group he leads for gay and bisexual married men. He says he urges men to think very seriously about what they'll be giving up if they choose to quit their marriages, if they choose to be honest with their families, if they choose to end their double lives.
你需要多了解一个人才能爱他，才能和他生活在一起？杰瑞说，在他领导的已婚男同性恋和双性恋支持小组中，他每年会接触大约260人。他说他敦促男人们认真思考，如果他们选择结束婚姻，如果选择对家人诚实，如果选择结束双重生活，他们将会失去什么。
Coming up, lies that every parent tells, including a secret that my mom has kept from her kids. And yes, it involves sex. Yes. In a minute, when our program continues.
接下来，每个父母都会说的谎言，包括我妈妈对我隐瞒的一个秘密。是的，它和性有关。是的。稍后，节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and artists to take a whack at that theme with monologues, documentaries, short fiction, short radio plays, anything we can think of. Today's program, Double Lives. Act Three, Lighten Up.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会设定一个主题，邀请各种作家和艺术家围绕这个主题进行创作，形式包括独白、纪录片、短篇小说、短广播剧，任何我们能想到的形式。今天的节目主题是“双重生活”。第三幕，放轻松。
Up until now, we've been hearing about pretty serious lies, told between parents and children. But there are lots of trivial lies that parents tell. In fact, you can reasonably argue that it is impossible to raise children without lying to them, which brings us to the Neo-Futurists. The Neo-Futurists are a Chicago group who perform 30 plays in 60 minutes every Friday and Saturday night. And they prepared this play, they call it a play. I think non-Neo-Futurists would call it a sketch. They prepared this play on our theme today. It's by Greg Allen, a recent father himself.
到目前为止，我们听到了关于父母和孩子之间非常严重的谎言。但父母也会说很多无关紧要的谎言。事实上，你可以合理地认为，不欺骗孩子就无法抚养他们，这让我们想到了“新未来主义者”。“新未来主义者”是芝加哥的一个团体，他们每周五和周六晚上会在60分钟内表演30出戏。他们准备了这出戏——我想称之为戏。我想非“新未来主义者”会称之为小品。他们针对我们今天的主题准备了这出戏。作者是格雷格·艾伦，他本人也是一位刚当上爸爸的人。
Twenty-one lies I will tell my children. Go. Number one.
我会对我的孩子们说的二十一个谎言。开始。第一条。
If you don't get down, you're going to break your neck.
如果你不下来，你会摔断脖子的。
Two.
第二条。
Santa's coming.
圣诞老人要来了。
Three.
第三条。
Mommy was just, um, singing. Go back to bed.
妈妈刚才只是，嗯，在唱歌。回去睡觉吧。
Four.
第四条。
I will never forget this for as long as I live.
我这辈子都不会忘记这件事的。
Five.
第五条。
I'm sure he didn't mean to hurt you.
我相信他不是故意伤害你的。
Six.
第六条。
I said shucks. Oh, shucks.
我说的是“该死”。噢，该死。
Seven.
第七条。
Sure. I like your music. It's just different.
当然，我喜欢你的音乐。只是风格不同而已。
Eight.
第八条。
One more time and you're going to get out and walk.
再有一次你就给我下车走回去。
Nine.
第九条。
Just because your friends do it, doesn't mean you have to do it.
别人家的孩子都这么做，不代表你也得这么做。
Ten.
第十条。
Oh now, you don't really mean that.
哦，别这样，你不是真心的。
Eleven.
第十一条。
Sure. I like your haircut. It's just different.
当然，我喜欢你的发型。只是风格不同而已。
Twelve.
第十二条。
I never said that.
我没说过那种话。
Thirteen.
第十三条。
No one is going to notice a little pimple.
没人在意长个小痘痘的。
Fourteen.
第十四条。
Sex is the expression of love and devotion.
性是爱与奉献的表达。
Fifteen.
第十五条。
It doesn't matter about the new car. All that matters is that you're OK.
新车怎么样不重要，重要的是你没事就好。
Sixteen.
第十六条。
I'm going to kill you.
我要杀了你。
Seventeen.
第十七条。
Sure. I like your boyfriend. He's just different.
当然，我喜欢你的男朋友。他只是有点不同。
Eighteen.
第十八条。
I was just closing my eyes for a minute.
我只是闭眼休息了一小会儿。
Nineteen.
第十九条。
You were the best baby in the world.
你是世界上最乖的宝宝。
Twenty.
第二十条。
Everything is going to be all right.
一切都会好起来的。
Twenty-one.
第二十一条。
Daddy will always be here to take care of you.
爸爸永远会在这里照顾你。
Curtain.
谢幕。
Greg Allen, Diana Slickman, Dave Awl, Heather Riordan, David Kodeski, Anita Loomis, and Stephanie Shaw, of the Neo-Futurists.
格雷格·艾伦、戴安娜·斯利克曼、戴夫·奥尔、希瑟·里奥丹、大卫·科德斯基、安妮塔·卢米斯和斯蒂芬妮·肖，“新未来主义者”成员。
Our parents can surprise us with what they don't tell us, with what they don't talk about, especially when it comes to sex. Recently, I had this experience. An ex-girlfriend was in the gym, looking through a copy of a Marie Claire magazine, a woman's magazine. And there was an article in it on women's fantasies, their sexual fantasies, "What Do Your Man's Dirty Daydreams Reveal About What He Wants from You?" In the article, six sexperts-- that was the word they used, sexperts-- reveal the six most common male sex fantasy scenarios. So my ex-girlfriend is reading. And there, in the third paragraph, one of the sexperts turns out to be my mother.
父母那些不告诉我们的事，那些他们闭口不谈的事，尤其是涉及到性的时候，常常让我们感到惊讶。最近，我就有过这样的经历。一位前女友在健身房看一本叫《嘉人》的女性杂志。里面有一篇文章讨论女性的幻想，她们的性幻想——“你男人的那些肮脏白日梦揭示了他对你的什么渴望？”在文章中，六位“性学专家”——他们是这么称呼的——揭示了男性最常见的六种性幻想场景。我前女友正在读。就在第三段，其中一位性学专家竟然是我母亲。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello.
喂。
Hey, Mom.
嘿，妈。
Yeah.
嗯。
It's Ira.
是艾拉。
Yeah.
嗯。
So I'd like to do a little interview.
我想做一个小采访。
OK.
好的。
OK. So Mom, can I read to you a quote from an article?
好的。妈，我可以读一段文章里的引语给你听吗？
Of course.
当然可以。
OK. Here it is. "Your man wants a woman who excites him through her own excitement. You could stimulate yourself while he watches or let him participate by moving his hand to where you want it."
好。在这里。“你的男人想要一个能通过自身兴奋来让他兴奋的女人。你可以在他观看时进行自我刺激，或者引导他，把他的手放到你想要他放的地方。”
Yeah.
嗯。
That's you being quoted in Marie Claire.
这就是你在《嘉人》杂志里被引用的内容。
[LAUGHTER] You're kidding. What issue?
[笑] 你在开玩笑吧。哪一期的？
All I know is that Anaheed was at the gym. And she opens up Marie Claire to an article called, "Men's Sexual Fantasies." And it says at the top here, "Sexperts reveal the six most common scenarios, unlock the secret longings and psyches of the modern men who fantasize." And you, basically, are one of this sexperts.
我只知道阿纳希德在健身房，她翻开了《嘉人》杂志，看到了一篇题为“男人的性幻想”的文章。顶部写着：“性学专家揭示了六种最常见的场景，解开那些有幻想的现代男人们的秘密渴望和心理。”而你，基本上就是这些性学专家之一。
Yeah. Yeah, I am.
是啊，确实是我。
I didn't really know you were a sexpert?
我真的不知道你是性学专家？
What did you think I was?
那你以为我是什么？
[LAUGHTER]. Just another Jewish mom and psychologist.
[笑] 只是另一个犹太母亲和心理学家。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
So it wasn't like you were a sexpert and you were keeping it from your family?
所以并不是因为你是性学专家，而是在向家人隐瞒？
Um. You're talking about my family, meaning my children, not my husband?
嗯，你说的家人是指我的孩子，而不是我的丈夫吗？
Yeah.
对。
Because he knows that I'm a sexpert.
因为他知道我是性学专家。
[LAUGHTER].
[笑]
And you can call him to verify that.
你可以打电话去向他核实。
I think I'm just going to let that go.
我想我还是算了吧。
But my children always seem embarrassed if I discuss anything sexual. So therefore, I tend not to around them.
但我的孩子们似乎总是因为我讨论性相关的话题而感到尴尬。因此，我在他们面前通常会避免谈论。
When would you try to discuss something sexual with us?
你什么时候试图跟我们讨论过性相关的话题？
I might make a joke or say something that had a sexual connotation, and I'd get this disapproval.
我可能会开个玩笑或说些带有性暗示的话，然后就会得到这种不赞成的反应。
I don't think that that's true.
我不觉得那是真的。
No?
不是吗？
Yeah. I mean it doesn't affect me in any way to think that you and Dad would be sexual with each other. In fact, I even remember as a teenager understanding that and being kind of reassured by it.
是啊。我是说，想到你和爸爸之间有性生活，对我来说没有任何影响。事实上，我甚至记得在十几岁时，理解这一点反而让我感到某种慰藉。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
Does that make any sense?
这有什么道理吗？
It makes a little bit of sense. But it really doesn't cover all the situations, if I'm just telling a joke or talking about somebody else. And I think it has to do with boundaries. And I think it has to do with that children, even adult children, do not like to regard their parents' sexuality.
有一点道理。但这并不能涵盖所有情况，比如我只是开个玩笑或谈论别人。我认为这与界限有关。我认为孩子们，甚至是成年子女，都不喜欢去关注他们父母的性生活。
Hm. You know something, you're actually convincing me. [LAUGHTER] Well, let's do a little scientific test. Can you think of a sexual joke? You just tell one, right now. And I'll tell you my reaction.
嗯。你知道吗，你其实说服我了。[笑] 那么，我们来做一个小小的科学测试。你能想到一个性笑话吗？你现在就讲一个，我会告诉你我的反应。
I can't think of one.
我想不出一个来。
[LAUGHTER] You know what I'm feeling right now? I'm feeling a profound--
[笑] 你知道我现在是什么感觉吗？我感到一种深深的……
Oh, actually I heard a wonderful--
哦，其实我听过一个很棒的……
Wait a minute, no--
等等，不……
I heard a wonderful joke, but I don't even know if it's a joke or story. Because this is like something that might be true.
我听过一个很棒的笑话，但我甚至不知道它到底是笑话还是真实故事。因为它听起来像是真的一样。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
That when Neil Armstrong walked on the moon, and he said, one giant step for man and one-- what is it? One giant step for mankind or whatever--
当尼尔·阿姆斯特朗登上月球时，他说，这是个人的一小步，是什么？这是人类的一大步还是什么？
One small step for a man, one giant step for mankind.
这是个人的一小步，是人类的一大步。
Right. Right. That's it. Right. One small step for man, one giant step for mankind. And then, he also said, "Good luck, Mr. Gorki." And for years people have been asking him what that meant? And he would never tell them. And then this year, someone brought it up again, what did you mean when you said, "Good luck, Mr. Gorki?
对，对。就是这样。对。这是个人的一小步，是人类的一大步。然后，他还说了一句：“祝你好运，戈尔基先生。”多年来，人们一直问他那是什么意思，但他从不肯说。今年，又有人提起了这件事，你说的“祝你好运，戈尔基先生”是什么意思？
And he said, well, I can tell now, because Mr. Gorki died this year. When I was a little boy, Mr. Gorki was our next door neighbor. And I was playing outside one day. And their bedroom window was open. And I heard Mrs. Gorki say, "Oral sex? You want me to give you oral sex? You'll get oral sex from me the day that boy next door walks on the moon."
他说，嗯，我现在可以说了，因为戈尔基先生今年去世了。当我还是个小男孩时，戈尔基先生是我们隔壁的邻居。有一天我在外面玩，他们卧室的窗户开着。我听见戈尔基太太说：“口交？你想让我给你口交？等你隔壁那个男孩登上月球的那天，你再想从我这得到口交吧。”
[LAUGHTER] Well, now I'm examining my own feelings. And I have to say, I did get very nervous there, in a way that does not correspond, perhaps, with shrugging my shoulders at the notion of you having some sexual life and sexual thoughts.
[笑] 好吧，现在我正在审视我自己的感受。我不得不说，我确实变得非常紧张，这种感觉和我对于你拥有性生活和性想法而耸耸肩的态度，或许并不一致。
Yeah.
是啊。
So let me read you some of your other quotes here.
那我再读一下你其他的引语。
All right.
好的。
In the fantasy of man dominates woman, you're quoted as saying-- says Dr. Glass, quote, "In a caring relationship, it's certainly not abusive or unhealthy if the fantasy is played out in a light, teasing way." You're also quoted extensively in fantasy number five, spontaneous encounter with a beautiful stranger. The key quote is this one, as far as I'm concerned, "Go to a restaurant, and at first pretend you don't know each other," suggests Dr. Glass. Which when I read that, it actually explained some dinners I've had with you and Dad,--
在关于男人支配女人的幻想中，你是这样被引用的——格拉斯博士说，“在一段充满关怀的关系中，如果这种幻想是以轻松、戏谑的方式呈现出来的，那绝非虐待或不健康。”你在关于第五种幻想，即“与美丽的陌生人发生自发邂逅”中也被大量引用。我认为关键的引语是这一句：“去一家餐厅，起初假装你们互不认识，”格拉斯博士建议道。当我读到这一条时，它确实解释了我曾和你以及爸爸一起去吃饭时遇到的一些情况……
[LAUGHTER]
[笑]
--I thought. Well, you didn't talk very much between the two of you.
……我当时想，你们俩之间话还真不多。
No. No. That's just the opposite.
不，不。正好相反。
Have you done this? Have you gone to a restaurant with Dad and pretended you didn't know each other?
你们做过吗？你们去餐厅时假装彼此不认识？
No.
没有。
No. But if you did, you're saying that--
没有。但如果你们做了，你是说……
We've gone to restaurants with you and pretended we didn't know you.
我们跟你一起去餐厅时，假装我们不认识你。
[LAUGHTER] What do you mean by that?
[笑] 你这话是什么意思？
Well, when you were younger and--
嗯，当你还小的时候，而且……
[LAUGHTER]
[笑]
--let's say that your manner of dressing didn't exactly conform to the style--
……假设你的穿衣风格并不太符合……
All right, all right, all right. I think everybody-- yeah.
好了，好了，好了。我想每个人……是的。
--that the people in the restaurant. Daddy would look at you. And he would start popping Gelusil, before we'd go out to eat. And I'd say, now Barry, people are going to look at him and they're going to look at us, and they're going to know that we did not pick out his clothes.
……餐厅里其他人的风格。爸爸会看着你，他在我们出去吃饭前就会开始吃胃药。我会说，巴里，人们会看着他，然后看着我们，他们会知道他的衣服不是我们选的。
So now that I know that you're this big sexpert, do you have any sex advice for me?
既然现在我知道你是位伟大的性学专家，你有什么性方面的建议给我吗？
Find a nice girl and get married.
找个好女孩结婚吧。
That's not sex advice.
那不是性建议。
We always end up this way, don't we?
我们总是以这种方式结束，不是吗？
With that particular advice, yeah. That's the lady I know. I could ask you any question and that would be the advice.
用那种特定的建议，是的。这就是我认识的女士。我可以问你任何问题，得到的建议都会是这个。
Well, that was the first rule of journalism you taught me.
嗯，那是你教我的新闻学第一准则。
Is what?
是什么？
No matter what they ask you, be sure to get your point in.
无论别人问你什么，都要确保把你的观点表达出来。
You mean when you were first being interviewed by people, this is what I told you to say.
你是说当你第一次接受别人采访时，这就是我告诉你要说的话。
Right. Right.
对，对。
Well, I'm glad we got to that then.
好吧，很高兴我们谈到了这个。
My mom. Dr.  Shirley Glass, in Baltimore.
我的母亲，巴尔的摩的雪莉·格拉斯博士。
Act Four, Sins of the Fathers. What does it do to children if parents tell a big lie for years? Part of Susan Bergman's book, Anonymity, is her trying to understand the two parts of her father, strict, religious, family man; promiscuous, gay, night clubber. His personality was split in half, she writes, into two irreconcilable halves.
第四幕，父辈的罪孽。如果父母多年来撒下弥天大谎，会对孩子造成什么影响？苏珊·伯格曼的书《匿名》的一部分，是她试图理解她父亲的两面性：严谨、虔诚的顾家男人；滥交、同性恋、夜店常客。她写道，他的性格一分为二，变成了两个不可调和的部分。
But part of her book is about her discovery that growing up in his home, she became somebody who was also split in half, somebody able to carry on a life with two irreconcilable parts. She found herself as an adult, leading a double life. To end our program, we asked her to read from her book.
但她书中的一部分是关于她的发现：在那种家庭中长大，她也变成了一个性格分裂的人，一个能够维持两种不可调和生活部分的人。成年后的她发现自己过着双重生活。在节目的最后，我们请她朗读了她的书。
I pretend I am a faithful wife. My husband is married to that faithful woman. The woman looks like me. She moves around in my body. This is what I mean. You can't tell by looking. He makes love to her. He has asked her a question once or twice, and she has heard herself reply with an avoidance, "Is there anything you haven't told me? I want to know more of you, Susan."
我假装自己是一位忠诚的妻子。我的丈夫娶了那个忠诚的女人。那个女人长得像我。她在我的身体里活动。这就是我的意思。你光看是看不出来的。他与她做爱。他曾一两次问过她一个问题，而她听到自己含糊其辞地回答：“有什么你还没告诉我的吗？我想更多地了解你，苏珊。”
They spent last evening on opposite ends of the house, keeping things going, changing the music, refreshing people's drinks and trays of food. "What makes you ask that tonight after such a great party? All our friends here, scrumptious food. Didn't you enjoy yourself?" She unfastens her gold-beaded bracelet and folds it carefully into its silk-lined box, replacing the lid. "I saw the way Tom looked at you." "There's absolutely nothing for you to worry about between me and anyone here tonight. Most definitely nothing's up with Tom."
他们昨晚在房子的两端度过，维持着局面，换音乐，招待客人，补充饮料和盘中的食物。“在这么棒的派对之后，你怎么会问这个？我们所有的朋友都在，食物美味。你没玩得开心吗？”她解开金珠手链，小心翼翼地把它折叠进丝绸衬里的盒子里，盖上盖子。“我看到汤姆看你的眼神了。”“我和今晚在场的任何人之间绝对没什么可担心的。汤姆那儿绝对什么事也没有。”
She concentrates on slowing down, as she hangs up her belt and tosses her stockings in a basket of hand washing. "You're doing this jealous thing again. What kind of look?" "Do you have any secrets from me?" "A few." She'll keep it light. "This is not my natural hair color, quite. But the rest is real."
她集中精神放慢动作，挂起腰带，把长袜扔进洗涤篮里。“你又在胡乱吃醋了。什么样的眼神？”“你有事瞒着我吗？”“有一点。”她会轻松地带过。“这不是我天生的发色。但剩下的都是真的。”
You must understand that lying is a temporal invisibility. It's the leaves you wrap yourself in when the voice in the garden calls. I was learning to deflect any doubt or question about my faithfulness, back onto the questioner, so that I didn't have to perpetuate the lie. I had for years, part lied, but mostly told the truth. Two and more irreconcilable parts, which let me understand my father, or made me into him. Here was my father's ailment again, his dread of being known.
你必须明白，撒谎是一种暂时的隐身。当园子里的声音呼唤你时，谎言就是你用来包裹自己的叶子。我当时正在学习如何把对他人的怀疑或关于我忠诚度的质疑挡回去，转而抛向提问者，这样我就不必继续维持这个谎言了。多年来，我部分在撒谎，但大部分时间是在说实话。这两个互不相容的部分让我理解了我的父亲，或者说，把我变成了他。这就是我父亲的顽疾再次显现：他害怕被别人了解。
There's a family with children on the line. I force my family to serve as the same kind of false front I was raised to be from my father. Our presence testified to his normality. We failed, no matter how we strove for blessing, to discover the root of our calamity. I can't shake his choice alone, I tell myself. So we slipped and fell, which is human. And he died, stuck. And this gluey lie I keep perpetuating, sticks to me like a curse, revisited on the next generation. My father is in the window when I glance up, and in the hurried tone of my voice, in the shape of my ribs. What if, lights on, as is, he had asked us to love him?
有一家人带着孩子在排队。我强迫我的家人扮演和我父亲当年要求我扮演的一样的虚假门面。我们的存在证明了他的正常。无论我们如何努力寻求祝福，我们都没能发现我们灾难的根源。我告诉自己，我无法独自摆脱他的选择。于是我们滑倒并坠落，这是人之常情。而他死的时候，依然深陷其中。这种我一直在延续的黏糊糊的谎言，像诅咒一样粘在我身上，又在下一代身上重演。当我抬头看时，我父亲就在窗边，我的说话语调变得仓促，连我的肋骨形状都像他。如果当初灯火通明，维持原状，他直接要求我们爱他，会怎样呢？
I opened the book I had slipped into my jacket pocket and read, "Lord, who shall abide in thy tabernacle? Who shall dwell on thy holy hill? He that walketh uprightly, and worketh righteousness, and speaketh the truth in his heart. Who shall ascend into the hill of the Lord? Or who shall stand in his holy place? He that hath clean hands, and a pure heart; who hath not lifted up his soul unto vanity; nor sworn deceitfully." If her hands are clean and her heart pure, I had been forgiven. But I had yet to go to the man I had wronged, and whom I desperately wanted to love me, to cancel my ongoing lie, my maintaining the family pattern of dishonesty.
我翻开滑进夹克口袋里的书，读道：“耶和华啊，谁能寄居你的帐幕？谁能住在你的圣山？就是行为正直，作事公义，心里说实话的人。谁能登耶和华的山？谁能站在他的圣所？就是手洁心清，不向虚妄，起誓不怀诡诈的人。”如果她的手是干净的，心是纯洁的，我应该已经被宽恕了。但我还没有去见那个被我伤害过，且我极度渴望他能爱我的人，去终结我正在进行的谎言，去停止维持那个家族不诚实的模式。
My husband couldn't bear ever to look at me again. Hadn't my family put him through enough already? Wasn't I a hard pill he had to swallow and swallow? He would remarry within the year, a woman of fidelity and beauty and a way with children, my children. What kinds of stories would they be told about me? All that we had made together-- I took inventory-- did not add up to the ultimate banishment of the untruthful from the presence of God.
我丈夫再也无法忍受看我一眼。我的家人对他造成的伤害还不够吗？我难道不是他不得不一次又一次吞下的苦果吗？他在一年内就会再婚，娶一位既忠诚又美丽，还很擅长照顾孩子（我的孩子）的女人。他们会被告知关于我的什么故事呢？我清点了一下——我们共同创造的一切，最终加起来也无法抵消不诚实之人被上帝拒之门外后的结局。
If you give me the opportunity Lord, one more time, whatever the consequence, I prayed, I will tell the truth. Judson put the question simply, the same one as before. That morning, I had sat in the sun, and read, and drunk my coffee, uninterrupted. Maybe it was a morning unlike any my father had ever been given. When Judson came home later that morning, is when he asked, "Is there something you'd like to tell me?" There was a reason my husband was unable to retire his doubts. I had made an offer of honesty, yes, but hadn't thought the test would come so soon.
主啊，如果你再给我一次机会，无论结果如何，我祈祷，我会说实话。贾德森提出了那个问题，很简单，和之前的一模一样。那天早上，我曾坐在阳光下，看书，喝咖啡，没人打扰。也许那是一个我父亲从未得到过的早晨。那天晚些时候贾德森回来时，他问：“有什么想告诉我的吗？”我丈夫无法放下他的怀疑是有原因的。我的确提出过要诚实，是的，但我没想到考验来得这么快。
Walking out on the plank of my own promise, I peered down at the water. First, you leave your father's house, and then your own. There was a deep gulf below me I could not see into. This was the last of my life, as I knew it. "Whatever the consequence," I said inside my head to remind myself, breathing once. He could tell in the stillness of the pause between his question and my looking back up at him, that his life was changing too.
走在我自己承诺的跳板上，我低头看向水面。首先，你要离开父亲的家，然后离开你自己的家。我脚下有一个我看不到的深渊。这是我所知的余生的终点。“无论结果如何，”我在心里对自己说，提醒自己，呼吸了一次。在他提出问题和我抬头看向他之间，那寂静的暂停中，他能感觉到他的人生也正在改变。
Today's program was produced by Alix Spiegel and myself, with Dolores Wilber, Peter Clowney, and Nancy Upkike. Contributing editors Margy Rochlin, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Sarah Vowell. Musical help today by John Connors, Steve Cushing, and the mysterious and elusive Rumpety Rattles.
今天的节目由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和我制作，多洛雷斯·威尔伯、彼得·克劳尼和南希·厄普代克参与制作。特约编辑：玛吉·罗克林、保罗·托夫、杰克·希特和莎拉·沃威尔。今天的音乐协助由约翰·康纳斯、史蒂夫·库兴，以及神秘而难以捉摸的朗普蒂·拉特尔提供。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
To buy a tape of this or any of our This American Life programs, they're only $10, call us at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] .
如需购买本节目或我们《美国生活》任何节目的磁带，仅需10美元，请致电芝加哥WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380，312-832-3380。我们的电子邮箱地址是[email protected]。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, whose mother never says things like--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他的母亲从不会说这种话——
Oral sex? You want me to give you oral sex? You'll get oral sex from me the day that boy next door walks on the moon.
口交？你要我给你口交？除非隔壁那男孩能上月球，否则你别想从我这儿得到口交。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week, with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。